any regrets you know it's funny the way
the world works you know if I had stayed
on the show and been there during season
six and shot and all that kind of stuff
I wouldn't have met Nadia
you know Wow and I wouldn't be getting
married and I wouldn't be at this place
in my life where I feel really sort of
in line with what I am meant to be doing
personally and professionally Daniel
listening announced his departure from
when calls the heart nearly two years
ago and now he's busy working on a new
show and planning his wedding more on
that later but first the actor is
reflecting on his decision and revealing
to ET the heartwarming reason why he has
no regrets no regrets at all I mean how
can I look at my future wife and say oh
I should have stayed on this job she's
my life you know like that's my personal
life and that's exponentially more
important to me than than a job but with
that said there's no doubt Daniel is
still a mega Hardy this Sunday February
23rd is the season 7 premiere of one
calls Lord I think I love to see you
cheering it's so clear that you're still
such a fan of the show of course will
you be tuning in this weekend I will
they're doing a great job do you think
about the direction the show is going in
I think it's great you know that keeping
it positive you know after you know Jack
Jack's death it was a really dramatic
season they have bought in two love
interests for Erin's character and they
I mean they're going great the ratings
are fantastic I mean ya know I'm I'm so
happy that the show is doing so well it
will continue to do well is there still
part of you that misses going to that
set every day do you feel nostalgic sure
you know sometimes I really miss living
in Vancouver getting picked up by my
driver uncle Gary it is a family yeah
and that aspect of things I really miss
I love all the costs people at Hallmark
my time with ol Mark was nothing but
positive and truly grateful I love
reading
the Hardys theories about possible ways
if you are down that you could come back
right there's one theory I really love
that someone wrote that in a dream where
Elizabeth is kind of getting closer to
making a decision between one of the two
suitors a hook in this dream jack comes
to her and either gives her some advice
or some guidance or gives him gives his
blessing to her huh I mean would you be
down to come back in a much fun I mean
just to go out there and see everyone
again yeah have that opportunity yeah I
can see my old horse you know Taylor
give you a Bachelor of course I mean
that was such a good part of the job you
know look you know if if pulmonic called
me for anything you know that were there
for me for five years so of course you
know I love those guys anytime a lot of
fans feel conflicted and they can't seem
to really let go of the Jack and
Elizabeth dynamic right what is your
message
I mean you played Jack so you know where
his mind is actually he would want her
to move on and find love with someone
new Jack and Elizabeth ayrton I had
serious chemistry without work we really
connected to these characters we we
built this show from day one together
and of course it's got to be it's got to
be difficult letting go of that you know
when you first fall in love with the
television show you kind of it's it's
hard to accept change that comes with
that with that show but I will say gotta
move on guys there's a couple of great
actors right there I think it's you know
time to embrace that at that storyline
saying that I'm so grateful that you
you love Jack so much so can we set the
record straight would Jack give his
blessing to Elizabeth to move on yeah I
think that when when he passed and
Elizabeth read his letter he he always
did find love again cuz that's all it is
you know at the end of the day he's not
gonna be there there's no point her
dwelling on that she needs to move along
she has to find well I know she's happy
in her own life and being a mom that's
it I know even if she can't find
companionship with someone else it would
be like the cherry on number one you
don't need a man to make you happy
let's just be clear about that preach
all right mm-hmm got to be happy in here
first
Elizabeth ease you know the man thing
it's just a cherry on top you know I'm
saying I never got a chance to work with
your on-screen son but uh how does it
feel to see baby Jack on screen it's so
funny you know like I know that that
little twins I I don't know them I've
never met them which is yeah right I see
yeah but any Aaron place their little
cuties yeah totally but little baby Jack
you know I mean I'm sure the character
Jack would feel my son I would have
loved to have seen you know between the
two of you I mean that would have been
really cute you know just just having
that uh
a good good dad role model from a
Mountie police officer to an actor
playing a cop on TV you can now catch
Dan on ABC's the rookie so what are you
up to this weekend the private training
thing right yeah this weekend could work
great but also we should eat
can't learn on an empty stomach it's so
exciting very like different role from a
Jack Thornton on when calls the heart
this time I'm playing a character named
Sterling Freeman in a gay relationship
with a police officer and he's an actor
as well so you know doing these kind of
different roles is always like exciting
to me you know what I mean it kind of
broadens my acting chops so to speak
he's an actor and you know you kind of
like exaggerated a little exactly
professional life is going great so is
Dan's personal life he and his fiancee
Nadia are getting married we're just
loving life together
we're wedding planning now as well which
I thought was gonna be a nightmare by
the way well what has been your
experience so far love wedding planning
Dan no I'm telling you it is so much fun
[Music]